what's up guys I'm here at the Singapore
Motor Show and we are here to show you
guys something very cool from Volkswagen
the first time in Southeast Asia it's
been shown to the public the DNA of the
iconic Volkswagen kombi and the ID Buzz
ID bus cargo and of course we've got the
id4 the all-electric SUV and the Golf R
which we just launched in Singapore
right here and uh let's see this bus
it's freaking awesome first off
Golf R just highlight real quick the
golf bar
fastest golf to date 320 horsepower 420
newton meters of torque underneath this
acropovich exhaust
this thing is Decked Out loaded but now
we move over to the electric side of
things the id4 now in other parts of the
world it's already been out but in
Singapore this is when it's officially
available here the first all-electric
SUV from Volkswagen needs to see the
design language very new design language
for Volkswagen very Sleek very modern
your distance range on a charge is
around 400 kilometers thereabouts and
it's awesome it looks really cool check
out the interior on this bad boy here
very evcentric a lot of tech inside of
this
look at that display if I can't watch
Netflix on that thing I don't know what
I can do on it but maybe I can game as
well who knows but that is freaking
amazing but of course everybody is
excited to see the ID buzz and ID Buzz
cargo
but before I show that to you
here's a quick message from our sponsor
this video is brought to you by Asus
check out the Asus Zenbook 14x OLED
Space Edition commemorating the 25th
anniversary of the first Asus laptop
sent into space Not only does it offer a
space exclusive design but it's even
worthy of going where no man has gone
before with its space grade durability
it even comes with a 3.5 inch OLED
companion Zen Vision display and you
will have a ball of a time taking
interviews with a 16x10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated 14 inch display
this is called the ID buzz from
Volkswagen this is kombi DNA the
Volkswagen bus essentially in ev4 what's
cool about this is the design look at
the front of the grill real quick here
they call this
the car that smiles because the grill
the way that it looks here it's like
it's a big smiley face I love the LED
lights on this and what's cool about
this is actually there's a separate
battery underneath this that powers this
and there's a battery of the course that
Powers the vehicle itself so this is
really cool comes in a variety of
different colors
um they are going to come out with a
seven seater version of this quite soon
but this is already pretty big and I
think for Singapore and for a lot of
Southeast Asian cities this will be more
than adequate but it's the interior
which is awesome check this out as you
can see from the design of the Interior
the color combination the orange we've
got this white sort of cream look to it
which is beautiful it's awesome I love
this kind of like wood finish to this
gives it something very naturalistic
very cool
beautiful large display love the white
border around that and the fabric here
is actually made out of recycled plastic
bottles so
obviously with the whole Eevee range
from a Volkswagen they want to be
environmentally friendly sustainable all
that stuff and that's right here in the
ID Buzz sit inside this thing
now I've driven a Comey before and the
Comey doesn't go that fast but it's a
lot of fun you can actually open up the
glass right there and have a glass with
this thing obviously you can't do that
with this it's more modern but this is
very roomy I'm about 1.83 meters and I'm
sitting here in the front seat and I've
got a ton of Headroom I mean I've cut my
hair recently but I still got a ton of
Headroom here okay Nigel's inviting me
to come over here to the driver's side
come inside Jackie
so as you can see here they've covered
this so people don't dirty up the
steering wheel but you get a cream white
steering wheel or kind of a stone white
steering wheel matches the whole
aesthetic of this this is very very
comfortable and I'm going to tell you
this is freaking awesome now the roof
doesn't open up at least not on this
version yet maybe that'll happen in the
future who knows but uh yeah
this is the ID Buzz let's go in the back
seat real quick on this in terms of
building in terms of Aesthetics
Everything feels really well made on
this so if you're thinking that
is this going to be you know inexpensive
we may know it feels very very premium
for what it is but it's got a fun vibe
to it and sitting back here again check
this out
actually we got
an airplane seat
kind of like that you can put your
laptop here you can work you can eat
I don't know if it comes with you know
ID Buzz attendance or not I have to ask
if that comes in the price but you got a
drink holder there you're pretty good
we need a drink we need a drink Zaki but
this is pretty cool pull that down but a
ton of room look at this I mean a lot of
room that I can go sit back here relax
this is very very roomy
been able to like retract all the way
back I think they should go all the way
down forward this way but I think can't
go all the way back because I mean well
also too I've got this piece right here
so it's probably hitting that so I don't
know how far it goes back the doors are
automatic too doors are automatic I
believe
I don't know try it
it's automatic Zaki it's automatic
dude
look at that and it stops you hit the
lever goes again
definitely see this as a
definitely a family vehicle and it's
about the size of the touring in case
you're wondering because while it looks
very large it might be slightly longer
than the torque but not by much it feels
very very roomy anyway let's go to the
uh the boot of this thing or the trunk
depending what part of the world you're
from
it's automated
[Music]
look at this
I guess you could sit on this
you can have a party back here think
about this we could have a barbecue we
can have coolers we can have drinks
tailgate party with the ID buzz but I
like this you got very different uh
Shelby's right here of course this is
for demo right here but you can move
this around then you got the cover back
here which you can remove but there's a
lot of storage
yeah it's actual shelves Because You
Gotta Have a Party in the ID Buzz it's
all about that
but yeah this is really really cool
let's check out the cargo real quick now
the second version is called the ID Buzz
cargo of course
really this is laid out if you want to
go camping put a bed back here
if you want to let's say if you're a dog
catcher or working for a kennel you
could put all that stuff you could put
all those cages in here as well
hey Jackie how are you
yeah it's a little bit uh different
inside here this is kind of bare bones
but
yeah I'm just going to give you an
example I'm 1.83 I'm laying back here
like this
and I'm sitting here this is the room
you got here in the ID Buzz cargo which
is pretty pretty long
not bad
and then you've got this glass partition
here so this is meant for people that
you want to throw in the back but you
don't want to talk to when you're in the
front
put put those friends back here you want
the cargo for that and uh the design
language is pretty reminiscent of the ID
buzz but it's not as I always say as
luxurious it's kind of you know
utilitarian in his design language but
yeah that's it
I got a lot of exits here Zacky a lot of
exits so in terms of the fabric here
it's still the same as the ID Buzz made
from recycled plastic bottles so it's
very environmentally friendly the design
language here is a little bit more
simplistic but it's still got that
futuristic design but of course we're
not going to have that those color
combos that we've seen on the ID Buzz
here in the ID bus cargo because this is
meant to be used for work if you don't
have to be so fancy for work
at least
but it still looks pretty cool I mean I
would rock this more plastic around this
area here more utilitarian but this is
great and I love the fact that you
yeah can't talk to anybody back there
all right so that in essence is some of
the new launches here at the Singapore
motor show the first time in Southeast
Asia as I mentioned that we're getting
to see the ID buzz and ID Buzz cargo
very awesome machines I think they're
going to be released here later this
year I know they're already released in
Europe but uh this is freaking Wicked
these are cool
that would be awesome
what color combination would you go
orange and white or would you do
something like this where it's blue and
white you gotta have the two-tone at
least you got to do two tone so I don't
know we'll figure that out anyway if you
guys like this video subscribe to the
channel hit that like button and check
out more of our reviews right here
[Music]
thank you